We've got a lot to cover and not much time to do it so let's dig right in.
Here's a game I'm playing online with my friend, Ken.
I'm winning by a little bit mostly because I got good letters like the Z and so on but Ken is catching up.
Let's dig right in and come up with our concept inventory. What have we got?
Well, the most obvious thing, there's a board, there's letters--both letters on the board
and letters in the hand, and the letters on the board have to form words and in the hand they're not.
There's the notion of a legal play on the board, so RITZY is a word,
and it's a word independent of where it appears, but it's legal to have placed it here
where it hooks up with another letter, and it wouldn't have been legal to place it
where it bumps into the H or where it's not attached to anything else.
There's the notion of score and the score for individual letters. Z is worth 10.
An I is worth 1, and there are scores for a play where you add up the letters.
Part of that is that there are bonuses on the board.
DL means double letter score. A letter that's placed there gets doubled. DW means double word score.
If any letter of the word is on that square, then the whole word
score is doubled, and we also have triples as well.
Somewhere behind the scenes, there's a dictionary
and all these words are in the dictionary and other combinations of letters are not.
Then not shown here is the notion of a blank tile.
Part of the hand might be a blank that isn't indicating any particular letter,
but you're free to use for any one, similar to the way we had jokers in the game of poker.